okay let's go to our caller from the
four to five area code caller from four
to five go ahead four to five David yes
that's you yeah Richard hey Richard
what's going on cutting out Richard and
I don't know if we're on speaker but can
we do anything to improve your
connection and audio
I'm not speaker as clearly as possible
good good good
hey I'm one of the federal workers
affected by the shutdown and you're not
receiving a paycheck and my question is
to avoid to solve this problem couldn't
the house put together a funding bill
that included basically an oversight
committee that would be bipartisan that
would choose how those funds would
ultimately be spent essentially you know
oversight that the language could
include funding for some kind of
physical barrier but that Oversight
Committee would be a check against the
president and you know it would be a way
to you know basically save face for both
sides you could do it the thing is I
don't know that either side is really
into that I agree with you that it would
be a way for both sides to plausibly
save face but Donald Trump has been
pretty clear that he just wants funding
for the wall Democrats have been pretty
clear that they don't so I totally agree
with you that there are a whole bunch of
ways that this could go forward I mean
you could even have a situation where
there's an agreement on everything but
the wall and a particular committee is
appointed to discuss the wall but
obviously yours that still going to
leave you with Republicans unsure that
it's going to happen and Democrats
unsure that it's not so you're
completely right I mean the there's a
it's and it's a ridiculous circumstance
we're in where they have not been able
to move forward on this and by they I
don't mean that it's equally Democrats
and Trump to blame I mean this is the
Trump shutdown but there are all sorts
of possibilities and it's it's going
nowhere so so far it's unbelievable
yeah can I just add real quick something
that hasn't gotten out in the news at
all and that's that we are being faced
very shortly with a second paycheck
being missed and as a result of that
what's gonna happen is our vision and
dental plans are gonna send us premium
bills to get those benefits that we will
have to pay full yep and I haven't
really been talked about in the news at
all that's specific we will keep our
health insurance but vision and dental
we could potentially lose if we don't
pay those high premiums at our own
pocket and correct me if I'm wrong all
right if you're paid bi-weekly aren't
you about to miss your third paycheck
well technically yes but it it it's
gonna cost basically 30 days with no pay
Ryan I guess once premiums are not paid
in those two those programs within 30
days they start mailing out bills and
that's the full premium including the
share the government would normally pay
right yeah and obviously I mean I'm
guessing when government reopens you
would be paid back for that but in the
minute in the interim you have to front
all that money yeah if we don't pay it
we lose that benefit for the whole year
in the soonest we can get it back would
be next year unbelievable unbelievable
thanks for thanks for sharing that yeah
that's I hope it gets resolved soon for
your sake and everybody else's ok that's
it for today I'm out of time sorry to
everybody I didn't get to will take
calls again appreciate everybody who
called in